meantime nhp needs your help to locate a  car  involved in a deadly hit-run crash this  happened around 2am on the us-95 at the  boulder highway  southbound off-ramp nhp says the silver  or gray older model sedan was traveling  on the u.s 95  approaching boulder highway at the same  time a man was crossing the ramp  directly in front of that car  the vehicle ran a red light and hit that  pedestrian who was within the marked  crosswalk  the driver left the scene the pedestrian  died at the hospital  police now are looking again for a  silver colored sedan with a broken  right headlamp and front end damage if  you have any information  you can call crime stoppers